i imagine if you're trying to find a new
apartment in japan you'd hope that like
the realtor was a sim so that you know
they'd
probably make getting a house in japan a
little easier i don't know
if you had difficulty getting an
apartment in japan i did mention this
actually on a members only stream
recently i i guess i'll go into it a bit
here but um
basically yeah it's been tough as a
reaper i would say
um kind of finding a um finding an abode
for me that because as a reaper it's a
little difficult yeah
yeah you know and you can say i do this
and this and this
oh yeah i don't care it doesn't really
matter does it
um so yeah but the good news is it
worked out in the end and for that i am
fortunate
that's that's the irony thing isn't it
it's like you could be like yes i am a
multi-millionaire
[Music]
do you speak japanese yeah how about
this thing that you have no control over
yeah
yeah okay well sorry but kindly [ __ ] off
so you want to buy this whole building
but you know it's all good i just wonder
if you know how to separate glass from
plastic it's just i i just i can't
i can't fathom if you look we don't have
an english like scene by the way yeah
are you going to be okay my apartment is
four bedrooms i don't need four bedrooms
i only use two of the bedrooms because
no other apartment would accept me right
so i ended up with a place with four
bedrooms and it looks so excessive when
like people come to my like why are two
of the rooms not being used yeah
i couldn't get anywhere else we go from
i don't have enough space to
put my mouth to
which you can have i don't do anything
with it i sometimes go in
it smells really weird i don't like
clean the smell you gotta clean it how'd
you clean tatami i think you should
throw water on it right
yeah there's like there's like special
like equipment that you can use
or something i mean yeah because you do
yeah because
it collects mold oh
yeah there's different ways that like
there's like certain i mean i've never
done it it doesn't matter because
they're charging me anyway when i leave
to replace it right yeah
if there's if there's animals living in
there when i leave
yeah i remember like the week that me
and sydney moved into our apartment
like she stains the tatami mat within
within the first few days
[Laughter]
and we didn't realize because we had uh
i think she'd like we'd like spill some
water over it or something
i remember her was it red bull i
remember her being like paranoid in the
group chat being like
how do i clean red bull from the map
[Music]
as a foreigner you just don't know how
to deal with tatami rooms right i'm like
can you put furniture in here
how the [ __ ] can we put anything in here
have you ever lived in a tatami room
i have actually did you like it back in
the day um
not really i mean it wasn't quite my
choice was it because i recall
uh back in the day they i kind of didn't
get to choose uh where i lived i was
moving to a new city
and um and they were just kind of like
okay go here this is your this is your
place and i
i waltzed in it was super old the walls
were actually kind of crumbling like
on the inside there was a really ancient
tatami actually i already had water
damage so
i i went ahead and water damaged it a
little bit more
but actually what i did was um i was
trying to figure out how to dry my
clothing
um because uh we had i had a washer
outside and i washed my clothing there
and um it was kind of my first
experience in this kind of room
and i thought to myself well i have to
hang these to dry right okay i'll just
do it in my house
so i hung it up and it was it was
dripping right and so oh
no yeah so i went ahead and i went to
sleep and i woke up and i thought to
myself what is that scent
what is that scent in my home and then i
looked over to the side and i looked at
the dark spot on the
tatami mat and i thought ah i see oh
that's weird
the good news is i just kind of ran away
and that was it
it's your problem one thing i will say
though that
no not not many foreigners get to
experience is sleeping on a futon
and i will say sleeping on a futon in a
tatami mats room is like
it's the best night of sleep i ever get
it's not i don't know i don't know what
it is about the feeling of just
sleeping on the floor i don't know it
kind of reminds me of grand like
sleeping at grandma's house or something
like that
yeah i love i personally love the tommy
rooney like god first told me that he
loved it i was just like that meme of
like is this some peasant joke like
i'm too much done this doesn't mean yeah
is this some peasant joke i'm too rich
to understand
because i have all to tell me i'm like
why would i have voluntary sleep on that
bed i don't know man like because like i
like it now i like it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
because when we go to ryokans we're free
yeah yeah exactly and like you know my
grandma's house was nothing but to tell
me right because it was in the middle of
but [ __ ] nowhere in like the japanese
countryside and sleep like just lying
down on that
in like on a summer day is like the best
[ __ ] nap you'll ever feel like it did
wonders for my back
oh yeah yeah strange
it's strange to think about that
sleeping on the floor is like
more like it feels more healthy for your
back and stuff than sleeping on a
bed elevated yeah it is weird right it's
kind of an oxymoronic almost
yeah they're like somehow the most
uncomfortable sleeping
right so that's that's that's how humans
have been sleeping for like most of them
all right
we're going back to the neanderthal
phases on the ground of course